BASTIEN LEGRAS: Who has already
tried Compute Engine?
Since it has been announced for
open sign-up only at I/O,
so now it's three weeks ago, I
can understand, because it was
a limited preview before.
Which means we had to manually
activate the product, because
it has been announced last
year at I/O, but now it's
really something you
can try this year.
So a bit of background.
We've been working on-- for
us, it's a very strategic
project, ultra strategic
project.
I think you all know
Amazon EC2.
I guess most of you maybe
have already used.
You understand that we are
going into that space.
So this is a big space.
We've been working for three
years on the virtualization
technology and Compute Engine.
So it's not a copy of what you
can find in other places.
It's really unique to Google,
so from the bottom up.
You know what [INAUDIBLE] was
explaining, that because of
our scale, we had to
build our product.
We have to design our server.
We have to build our
network layers.
And our machines are the same,
so the operating system, we
what we find, the best, we
strip it, and then we
customize it, because this
is our own hardware.
So at all the layers, this is
Google-only technology.
We don't use Apache.
We don't-- maybe for
internal stuff.
But for the project, we have
rebuilt web servers, file
system, as you can see, really
from the bottom up.
So that's why this
virtualization layer is
completely optimized for our
platform, our servers.
And what we see, and I hope
that you will try Compute
Engine, is that we managed to
have a very low footprint.
Which means between the physical
performance and the
virtual performance, there is
always a little loss, because
there is a virtualization layer
running on the machines.
Here, the footprint of this loss
is very, very, very thin,
because we've been
optimizing that.
So you almost have the
physical machine's
performance.
And what is also important is
that we've been working a lot,
that was in the early
specifications, on the we call
the noisy neighbors problem.
The noisy neighbors is that with
virtualization technology
you have on public cloud
usually, you have a virtual
instance running on a
physical machine.
But you are not alone,
of course.
You have neighbors, so other
customers that are running
their own virtual instance on
the same physical machine.
And let's assume there is a bit
of overbooking, when your
neighbors--
so co-locating on this
physical machine--
are hitting hard.
So maybe they have
a peak of load.
You will see your own
performance dropping.
That's something we want to
avoid with Compute Engine.
We've been working hard on that
to do live migration of
machines when a physical machine
becomes noisy, so you
have your performance from
day one to the end.
And you have constant
performance over time.
You don't have performance
[? risks. ?]
The boot time and the
availability time as well is
really important.
You will see in the demo.
You have your machine in 20
seconds, more or less, so 20
seconds from the time you click
New Machine to the time
you can SSH the machine.
So it's not 5 or 10 minutes.
It's 20 seconds.
And the boot time
is really fast.
Like, it's less than 20 seconds,
because there is a
staging provisioning
time before.
Our objective is always
to have zero, but it's
impossible.
But we're trying to go
below one second.
So we are working really, really
hard on Compute Engine.
There is a lot of unknowns at
Google I/O that we made.
Like, we are providing now load
balancing, so level 3.
We are providing advanced
routine.
We are providing automation.
So there are a lot of features
coming on the project.
So a few slides,
and then demo.
What are the use cases, again,
about Compute Engine?
So the first one, hence the
name Compute Engine, was
compute, the idea of you can
launch any number of virtual
machines using Linux.
So today, we support Debian,
CentOS, and we have a core OS
which is GCL--
Google Compute Engine Linux--
which is like Ubuntu,
let's say.
And we're going to support
more operating
systems over time.
I can't disclose in a public
audience what we're going to
support, but in the following
months, we're going to support
more operating systems
that you all know.
The idea is that it's not
only the machines.
It's really about, again, as
always on a cloud platform,
the network.
The machine-to-machine networks
are incredible.
In less than one millisecond,
you can transfer terabytes, at
a terabyte per second.
Of course, you have
the physical
limit of the hard drive.
What I'm saying is that there
are almost no limits from the
network perspective.
The storage--
so there are two new
storage mechanisms.
We've been talking about cloud
storage, but you will still
have the local storage
on the machine.
That will live with the machine,
meaning that when you
create the machine, you
have this disk.
It's usually hundreds
of gigabytes.
It depends on how many cores
you want on your machine.
And I will show you after
doing the demo.
But you have also something I
mentioned earlier, which is a
persistent disk, which is a
shared storage, like a SAN, if
you want, across machines.
And there's a lot of tuning.
As always, you can use
the web REST API
to create your machine.
You can use the command line,
so gcutil, similar to the
gsutil I showed earlier.
Or you can, from the UI,
create the machine.
And that's something
I will do as well.
Because I need something
quite visual for you.
I have talked about
all of this--
scale, performance, value.
So that's the overview what you
get with Compute Engine.
So of course you get
what's right here,
so the virtual machines.
But you get a private network
within Google.
And you can do sub-networks, as
many as you want, set your
firewall rules.
And I hope you all understand
that you are root on this
machine, so this is your machine
running in Google
infrastructure.
That's really the idea.
So you do whatever you want.
And they are of course connected
to the internet, so
you can host an, I don't know,
website on Tomcat if that's
what you want to do.
Maybe you can't read
very well.
So this one was persistent
disk.
This one was local disk.
And this one is cloud storage.
So there's three main storage
mechanisms we provide.
And there's three access types,
so the command line,
the web UI, and from the code,
so the API itself, so either
the REST HTTP API, or using
a client implementation--
again, Java .NET, PHP,
you name it.
So what we call the project
is where all the
machines will be linked.
It's not physical stuff.
It's really a way to organize
your different applications.
So in one project, you have
all your machines.
You can go to another project
if you want to separate.
And within this project, you
have your own persistent disk,
local disk that comes with the
machine, network, et cetera.
And each project has an ID.
So the machine-- so as I said,
root access, there are stock
images you can use.
The idea is that you could
build your own images.
We are running a modem
processor, of course, so this
is Intel Sandy Bridge.
These are the virtual cores that
you can have from one.
Then even now, we have
launched at I/O
new very small modems.
Like if you do dev, we call
them small and micro.
I will show them.
But basically, you have from
one to eight virtual cores.
And per CPU, that's
the RAM you get.
And we have various profiles.
So we have what we call the
standard, which is this ratio.
We have high memory, so you
have more memory per core.
And we have high CPU So you
have less memory per core.
I don't know what happened.
Next.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
BASTIEN LEGRAS: Not yet, no.
The question was, can I create
a custom machine from the API
specifying the number of CPUs?
You have to go into the types.
I will show on the demo what
types of machines we provide.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
BASTIEN LEGRAS: That's the
high memory profile.
So I will show you
all the profiles.
I think you will see that
we are trying to address
the main use cases.
It's high memory profile what
you're talking about.
So let me finish with this slide
so I can show you that
right after.
So external IPs, of course you
can choose to add your own IPs
which are external IPs
for this machine
to listen on internet.
We are doing, of course,
one-to-one NATing, and firewall.
I will so everything
on the console.
This is the persistent disk.
So of course there are zones.
I forgot to mention, but when
you create your machine, you
choose if you want to deploy it
in US East, US Central, or
West Europe, where we bring more
availability zones, of
course, like in APAC,
because we are--
today, GC is not deployed
in all the data
centers that we have.
So it's only the first ones.
We are bringing more zones
so you can deploy your
application closest
to your customers.
And everything is encrypted in
time of storage at rest, and
even machine-to-machine
transfers are encrypted, which
gives you another idea
of the performance.
We are not even slowed
by the encryption.
So the ephemeral disk, so the
local disk, if you want, lives
and dies with the instance.
That's the idea.
You create your instance.
If you're in a compute scenario,
you don't care
what's on the machine.
You just create it.
Then maybe you want to set up
a launch script that will
configure the machine.
And the machine will do
some computation.
If you remember the use case
earlier with mobile and
back-end and VM engine
from App Engine.
That's typical [INAUDIBLE].
You create the machine, he's
going to do his job, and then
you destroy the machine,
and you don't care
what's on the machine.
So for that kind of use case,
you can use the local disk,
because it will die
with the machine.
If, however, you need to persist
the data generated by
the machine, then you want to
use the persistent disk.
And you can boot a machine
from the persistent disk.
That's really key, because you
want to minimize your cost.
So when you don't need the
machine anymore, you will
destroy it.
As it takes 10 to 20 seconds
to get the machine again,
there is no need to let
it slide the light.
When you go out of the room,
you switch off your light.
That's really the idea
of open engine.
You don't want to spend money
for a machine that is doing
nothing, of course.
So that's why you need to manage
your data, of course.
And the cloud storage, we just
talked about cloud storage.
That's, of course, integrated
with Compute Engine.
Again, easy to store terabytes
of data or petabytes of data
from Compute Engine.
And that was the case in the big
migration use case I was
showing before.
And the three access doors that
you have-- so UI, command
line, and from the API.
I won't go into too
much detail here.
We've covered that,
more or less.
So Compute Engine is
in most of our big
architecture diagrams.
So you see it, here it's a
Hadoop MapReduce use case.
Here it was the thing
of this morning.
I was presenting when you want
to do batch processing for
your mobile app on demand,
et cetera, et cetera.
This is an analytic pipeline,
so you have a lot
of data coming in.
You use App Engine for
MapReduce, and then you want
maybe to also use Hadoop
to analyze this data.
Compute Engine is everywhere.
I mean, everyone needs virtual
machines at one point.
It's very, very rare that you
don't need it in your project.
And before going into the demo,
so we already have, of
course, an ecosystem.
Right Scale is one of
the first partners.
So they know very well
Compute Engine.
They have their own image,
because that's the idea.
You can start from a cannot
machine, so a stock image,
then you can customize it,
and then you can take a
snapshot, of course.
You put it on cloud storage, and
then you will reuse it to
reboot a new machine.
So you have your own machines
in your project.
So Right Scale, they are
providing their own image.
And they added onto the image
a connector that connects to
their central console.
The idea is to have elasticity,
so scalability up
and down at the infrastructure
level.
We provide that with
App Engine.
As you know, it scales
up and down.
You don't have to worry about
how many machines you need to
run in your app.
When you are at the
infrastructure level, you have
to manage that.
So do I need to put
more machines
behind my load balancer?
So do I need to remove some
machines, because now I don't
have the demand for
all these machines
So Right Scale is doing
that for you.
You just configure.
You say, I don't know, you
define some threshold.
You say, at above 70% of usage,
I want you to add five
more machines.
And the rest of the inverse
rule, so when you go below
50%, you remove three
machines.
You define your own rules, and
Right Scale will manage the
scalability, so from
the console,
directly on Compute Engine.
And they do also a lot of
monitoring and stuff.
These are other partners,
technical partners.
MapR is a commercial Hadoop
implementation.
I have a project with them.
I was mentioning [INAUDIBLE]
earlier.
They are using MapR for a Hadoop
project to analyze the
traffic on the website
and improve
their conversion ratio.
So it works very well.
We broke the [? teraflop ?]
record.
It was one minute something.
With Compute Engine,
it's now less.
It's like 56 seconds.
So it's to give you an idea
of the pure performance of
Compute Engine.
I won't go into that.
It's the big data landscape.
Let's go on the demo for
the last 15 minutes.
So I have to sit down again.
Sorry.
And then I will take, of
course, questions.
So let me clean that up.
So you start from here.
Why is that there?
I hope you see.
So this is the console home
page for a project.
The console, let's go,
so you can understand
really how it works.
You go on here.
With your Gmail account, you
activate the services you want
to use, and then you create
your project.
And here I am logged with
my co-op account Google.
So we see we have some projects
internally that are
shared with me.
And I have access to this one,
which is our demo creator.
Here, you see the services
that are
activated for this project.
The project is like a team.
You can share the project with
other people in your team,
like you are sharing a doc in
Google Docs, and give specific
access to everyone.
So App Engine, so this means
that on this project, I guess
people are using some App
Engine instances.
Compute Engine, and we
will go into that.
Cloud Storage, Big Query,
some APIs, [INAUDIBLE].
There you see which services
are being used.
So let's focus on Compute
Engine, and then let's do a
quick tour of the Administration
Console.
Here you can see a basic
monitoring graph.
That's just showing nothing
is happening.
It's a demo environment.
There is no external user.
And we will give it some loads
during the next demo.
You can see the network traffic
as well that we are
monitoring, and disk traffic.
You will see here--
let me zoom--
that's a sample machine.
So that's the name
of the machine.
The machine is running.
You see the profile of the
machine-- one CPU, 3.8
gigabytes of memory.
Where is the machine?
So it's in US Central
this one.
How many persistent disks are
attached to this machine?
What is its external
IP address?
And on which network?
So that's a default network,
but you can create other
networks with other rules, on
which the machine is deployed.
And the images that the
machine is using.
Here you see there are
some Ubuntu, GCEL.
So that's a few machines we've
got on the project.
Machine doing fractal
stuff, which is the
point of the demo after.
You see there are some
write images, so I
guess it's Right Scale.
And you see all your machines
and which state
they are, et cetera.
So now let's focus
on a machine, so
that one, for example.
You can put some tags on your
machine if you want to
organize your machine
that way.
Again, as I said, you see the
zone, external IP, internal
IP, disks that are attached
to the machine.
So this one is mode
one, 10 gigabytes.
It has read and write access.
You can add metadata, which is
useful going to want to use a
launch script, et cetera,
with the API.
And then you will see the
permissions the machine has
with all the services.
And you can [? recognize ?]
storage, test use, Big Query.
So that's why I said we have
integrated the projects to
each other.
So let's create one machine
right now, so you
can see how it works.
Test Bastien One, and
description, tags, metadata,
so you add whatever
you want here.
There, you define where you
want the machine to be.
So you see I can deploy in
Europe or in US Central.
Today, more zones
are coming in.
So let's go in Europe West B.
And back to your question, the
types of the machines, so you
can see you have the new
machines, which are micro and
small, so very small, if you
don't need power I don't know,
it's like a machine that is
doing some networking stuff.
You have the high CPU profile,
where you see the number of
CPUs, and the low memory
best [? view. ?]
But if you need a lot of memory,
here you can see high
mem profile--
two CPUs, 13 gigs, or even
eight CPUs, 52 gigs.
That's the types of machines.
You cannot yet define your own
type, like I want a three CPU
or four CPU and 50 gigabytes.
You have to choose the
closest today.
MALE SPEAKER: So with the
RESTful API, is it only
possible to specify
if [INAUDIBLE]?
BASTIEN LEGRAS: Yeah, exactly.
And from the API, you can list
which are the templates,
because we are adding
new templates.
So you can release the templates
dynamically, and
say, OK, now I will take that
one because it's closest to my
requirements.
So that's a dynamic
list, actually.
And you have other machines with
what we call a scratch
disk, or ephemeral disk,
that was in my
slide, that local storage.
I can show them, by the way.
So when there is the-- so you
see the machine, and it's
local disk.
So let's take, I don't
know, anything--
high memory profile.
Then you can boot from an
existing persistent disk.
As I said earlier, if you need
to work on data you have
persisted earlier, or you can
just take the scratch disk or
a new disk that comes
with the image.
So let's do that.
Then you have the list of the
stock images we've got.
So we build them frequently, so
you can see here we have--
this is the US, so it's 7th of
May, 9th of May for Debian,
CentOS and GCEL here.
Or you can also save-- sorry.
I hope you can see.
If you can't see,
raise your hand.
Or you can save your
own images.
So other guys in my team, they
chose to create a Tomcat 6
type of server.
So it will have Tomcat already
pre-installed.
Because when we did the
snapshot, we had already
installed and configured
Tomcat.
So let's take a standard
machine.
And then you can add
other disks.
If the machine has to work we
shared data, you can add other
disks that you have
already created.
We got in a network.
So you will define in which
network you want
the machine to belong.
So let's keep the default.
And then external IP, if the
machine has to have an
external IP.
And here, the access.
So what it means is that if you
want the machine to have
access to storage, read and
write, or no access, or to
test use, we will pre-prog
this kind of access.
So in your bigger projects, if
you're using App Engine in
test use and you want this
machine to work with test use,
then you will give it
access right now.
Let's create the machine.
So that's where everyone
cross your fingers.
But basically, so
it's loading.
It's going to the stage the
machine into Europe West,
which is 20 milliseconds
from here, I think.
And then we will see it
directly in the list.
I have an error, but it's
not the same page.
It's not my concern.
Don't worry.
It's still creating
the machine.
It's another--
and that's the demo I will do,
by the way, right after,
hoping this one will work.
In this demo, we're going to
create one, and here we're
going to create 16, so 17
machines altogether, using--
this is an App Engine app.
And it's going to use the
REST API, of course,
to create the machines.
While it's still creating
there the machine.
I think in a few seconds, the
machine should be there.
Here it is.
It's being created.
So I guess it's alphabetical.
Here it is, coming in,
in Europe West B.
The machine is there.
OK, quite fast, finally.
I didn't measure.
I think it was 20 seconds,
something like that.
And the machine is available.
And if you want to connect to
the machine right away, you
have the REST snipped, or you
have the SSH command line you
can directly use in
your terminal.
So gcutil is the equivalent
of gsutil,
but for Compute Engine.
Let's clear that.
I just passed the command line
gcutil, last version.
That's the project--
Google Platform Demo, SSH,
in that zone, the
machine I just created.
Normally what would
happen, it would
ask for a login password.
But no, because we have
integrated everything.
So this is using OAuth.
It's not visible?
I'm going to zoom like
this, maybe.
MALE SPEAKER: No, but
you can just--
BASTIEN LEGRAS: Ah, sorry.
MALE SPEAKER: So you can
enlarge your fonts.
Yeah.
BASTIEN LEGRAS: That's OK now?
Sorry.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
BASTIEN LEGRAS: Good idea.
Good idea, [? Fredo. ?]
So I copied the GS2
command to SSH.
And as I said, I didn't have to
enter login password, which
is ultra-painful, by the way,
because what I've done is that
the first time you run gcutil,
it will send you to a URL.
You go to that URL
in your browser.
This URL will ask you to
authenticate against Google.
And if you authenticate
successfully, it will give you
the OAuth key that you copy
paste back in gcutil.
Which means that I have
authenticated gcutil to cloud
platform on behalf of me.
So now this gcutil installation
on my computer
has access to the machines
to which I am
authorized in the project.
You understand that?
It's very convenient, because no
need to log in, to remember
password or whatever.
And it's even more safe.
So we are on the machine.
So usually the demo stops there,
of course, because I
don't have much things
to show here.
I don't know.
Let's check if the memory
is the right one.
So we have our 26 gigabytes.
What about the CPU?
I need to--
I have a hard time--
OK.
CPU info, so here you can
see, it's really big.
My CPU numbers zero,
one, two, three.
So there are four CPUs,
as we asked.
And you see Intel Xeon CPU.
You see the technical
detail of the CPU.
So the machine is there.
I am root.
I can do whatever I want
on the machine.
So let me do another demo before
we finish, and take
some questions.
The demo is nice and visual,
I hope it's going to work.
OK, I don't want to mess up.
Sorry.
So this is an App Engine.
And this is a demo that has been
I think showcased at I/O.
This is App Engine.
And the idea of this demo--
this is a very
technological demo.
The idea is to start
VMs using the API.
That's what I'm going
to do right now.
And I need to show
in parallel.
Sorry.
It's for the demo to
be nice to see.
Sorry, I will have to do
something like this.
So I want you to
see that list.
And then the idea is
to start the VMs.
As you can see, it's
coming blue here.
So on the right, we have a
cluster, and on the left, a
single instance.
And here, on my poor console,
because I have [INAUDIBLE], we
should see as soon as it's
going to be refreshed.
Sorry.
I'm going to [? force ?]
refresh.
Normally it's refreshed.
OK, we're going to see
the fractal cluster--
which is the one
I'm creating--
that is being started.
OK, this is this one.
And on the right, the machine,
once they are green, the idea
is that the machines
are ready to SSH.
The program-- so App Engine
still, App Engine is going
onto the machines, provision a
little program that will run
some fractal imagery.
So it's pure scientific computer
calculation, so it's
using a lot of CPU.
And then we will display--
if it works, because
I am waiting also
for the single instance--
and display some fractal
imagery.
And one is a distributed
calculation.
The other is single.
So we see how fast the machines
work together,
because that's the type of use
case that requires a lot of
network also.
So the machines are there,
that just got created.
I hope I can show.
So I don't know why dimension
on the left, the single
instance failed.
But the idea is that the machine
on the right, as you
can see here, zooming out, have
been able to create their
own fractal.
And then it will mark on the
right the render time.
And it will calculate
as long as--
when I zoom here, with my two
fingers, it's calculating the
next layer of the fractal.
So sorry half of the demo
here is not working.
The idea--
imagine that on the left, you
have exactly the same thing,
but only one machine is
trying to do the job.
Here, we have eight machines
doing the same job.
So what we see on the left
usually is that the average
render time is much bigger,
because it's only one core.
And you can zoom,
you can zoom, it
will calculate, calculate.
So as soon as I zoom, it's
recalculated the fractal and
rendered that in a distributed
calculation.
Because all the machines are
doing the calculations.
And it's really pretty.
You can see the [? colors. ?]
so that's the idea
on how fast.
So how long did it take?
I don't know, 30 seconds.
And I could say three, eight, I
don't know, 128 machines, it
would be the same.
Because it's done in parallel.
We do that every
day at Google.
We have millions.
We don't say exactly how much,
but are in the millions range
in terms of size of cores.
And then you just stop, and the
machine will be destroyed
on the left.
So App Engine is asking--
OK, they are dying right now.
It's asking for the--
I don't know where they are.
They should go.
Maybe they already disappeared,
because they are
already red.
They already disappeared.
But usually you see
it live, also.
Here, you see the--
OK, here they are.
You see?
It's spinning right there.
They are dying, right there,
one after one.
And now they have disappeared.
I hope you caught it.
But it has destroyed the
machine, and then it's ready
back for another demo.
OK, I'm done for the
[? pres-- ?]
I can take some questions, if
you have, before we go into
the coffee break.
Yes?
We'll try to pass the mic.
[? We have ?] one mic.
Thanks.
MALE SPEAKER: Ciao, Bastien.
It's more a pricing question.
If I have some data, some files,
terabytes on the Cloud
Storage, and I launch 10 virtual
machines which share
the data on the cloud storage,
do I pay for
this internal exchange?
BASTIEN LEGRAS: So
good question.
So we don't charge for cloud
platform service to cloud
platform service network
exchange.
So what it means is that you can
do any traffic between App
Engine and Cloud Storage and
Compute Engine, between
Compute Engine machines, between
Compute Engine zones,
inter-network between Compute
Engine and of
course Cloud Storage.
It won't cost you anything
in terms of network.
What you will only pay
is your 10 terabytes.
MALE SPEAKER: The storage?
BASTIEN LEGRAS: So one terabyte
is $50, so you're
going to pay maybe
$500, I think.
I can show the pricing
[? slide. ?]
And then you will pay
for your machines.
Maybe you want to have a look,
because the pricing question I
think is interesting
for all of you.
It's fully public.
We have nothing to hide.
We are transparent.
So cloud.google.com, as you
understand, is the site to go.
This is everything.
From there, you can
find everything--
the project, the project
explanation, data sheet, the
website to developers where
you can see all the API
documentation.
And, of course, there
is the pricing,
and pricing by project.
So App Engine pricing is the
most complex, because we want
to be really fair, to really
price only what you use.
As you can see, you will
be priced by what
you are using exactly.
If you are using front-end
instances, dynamic, et cetera,
you have the price per hour.
Datastore API, we price
every 100k operations.
We have a very [? fine ?] rate
for that kind of pricing.
For storage, it's very
easier to understand.
There is always a free tier,
so you can try for free.
You have a free tier
five gigabytes
of storage, et cetera.
So you can try and
use storage.
We have two types of storage.
So the most replicated, and what
we call durable, reduced
availability, less replicated,
which is of course cheaper.
We do pricing in Euros, if you
want to pay in Euros with a
contract, et cetera.
And we price, of course,
depending on
how much you need.
So if you are in the 100
terabytes range, we will price
by gigabyte.
This is a gigabyte per month
price, that one.
So if you had 10 terabytes,
you can see, it's 54--
so $540 per month.
And for the network, as we say,
everything that goes into
the network is free.
Of course, we charge for the
network, so egress network
from Google to the internet
to your users.
And that's the type of price.
But there is no
service-to-service cost.
So internal Google transfers
are free, and then some
operation costs.
But every 1,000 application
operations is $0.01.
So basically you won't see it.
And Compute Engine, very key,
so that's really important.
That's something we announced
at I/O. So if you use the
machine six minutes, we're going
to charge 10 minutes.
If you use the machine 10
minutes, we charge 10 minutes.
If you use it 11 minutes,
we charge 11 minutes.
You see, so there is a minimum
set of 10 minutes, and then we
charge by the minute.
And then for all the machine
types you have seen earlier
when I was creating a machine,
you have a price depending if
the machine is in Europe
or the US.
And you have a price which is
per hour, so you can divide by
60 to have the by
minute price.
And you have a price for each
type of machine, of course.
So whether you need or not a
local disk on the machine, so
that's the size of
the local disk.
The high memory profile, so
you see two cores, 13
gigabytes, instead
of two cores.
So it's twice of it, almost,
up to 52 gigabytes.
So here is everything
[INAUDIBLE].
And here, it's a ratio CPU or
memory, whether that is
bigger, so less memory
per CPU.
If it's an [? HPC ?]
use case, you may want
to use that.
And you have the very new ones,
which are the small
ones, the micro and the small.
So we are at $0.021.
It's very small, about
$0.2 an hour.
And again, network pricing
between our services or in the
same zone is free.
We charge only external
network.
And then we reduce, depending
on the amount of network.
I'm not the commercial, but as
Kristoff said earlier, if
you're interested in a
professional contract with
support, you can see there are
several support packages,
which is there.
So we do up to Platinum with
dedicated account manager for
you, et cetera.
But we have the free one, so you
can, of course, access to
the [INAUDIBLE], to the Stack
Overflow, et cetera.
There's silver, so you
can do ticket.
You can call, call in.
And Gold--
and Gold is like, you have a
committed response time.
And you have all the various
commitments here, at the
pricing detail.
And if you are interested in
that type of support, if you
are in production, you have
customers, you need to make
sure it's going to be up, it's
not just test and development,
then you just contact
us right there.
That will arrive on
Kristoff's table.
So very simple.
Everything is there.
And on the videos, everything
is, if you search for Google
I/O sessions, you will
find them right here.
And you can choose your track,
and of course, my track is
Cloud Platform.
OK, I think we're good.
Maybe you want to have your
coffee break now.
[APPLAUSE]
BASTIEN LEGRAS: Thank
you very much.